قوات الدعم السريع استخدمت من قبل نظام
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير لقمع التمرد في
دارفور وقالت الامم المتحده انما ارتكب من
جرائم هناك يرقى الى جرائم حرب او جرائم
ضد الانسانيه ظهرت هذه القوات لاول مره
عام 2013 قوه شبه عسكريه تعرف قوات الدعم
السريع نفسها على انها قوات عسكريه قوميه
التكوين تعمل تحت امره القائد العام بهدف
اعلاء قيم الولاء لله والوطن وتتقيد
بمبادئ القوات المسلحه في عام 2017 صدر
قانون منح هذه القوات الشرعيه وعدل
القانون في عام 2019 بحتم ماده تلغي
خضوعها لاحكام القوات المسلحه اظهرت صعود
السريع لقوات الدعم السريع مدى اعتماد
البشير عليها لقمع التمرد ليس في دارفور
وحسب ولكن ايضا في كردفان والنيل الازرق
بعد اطاحه البشير في عام 2019 عقب
احتجاجات شعبيه طالبت برحيله اصبح قوات
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف
بحميتي نائبا لرئيس مجلس سياده الانتقالي
ما يمنح هذه القوات دورا في تشكيل المسار
السياسي في السودان ولا تقتصر سيطره قوات
الدعم السريع على الجانبين العسكري
والسياسي بل انها تعتمد على قوه اقتصاديه
من خلال السيطره على منجم ذهب في جبل عامر
بالاضافه الى حراسه مناجم في دارفور
وكوردوفان والانخراط في نشاط التعدين
والتجاره اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع بقمع
متظاهرين المطالبين بالحريه وقتل بعضهم
لكن ذلك لم يؤثر في نفوذ قائد احمدتي يقدر
عدد قوات الدعم السريع بنحو 100 الف رجل
منتشرين في مختلف انحاء البلاد وقد شاركت
في مهمات حربيه خارج السودان في اليمن
وليبيا مكن قائدها من نزع علاقات خارجيه
قوه موقعه في الداخل شارك في الانقلاب على
الحكومه الانتقاليه لعبد الله حمدوك في
اكتوبر 2021 لكن وبعد ان ظهرت خلافات مع
قياده الجيش قال انه ياسف لوقوع هذا
الانقلاب
من ق